The following is a meditation for the second
fundamental motivation of existential analysis.
Helping us answer the question of, do I
like being with an affirmative yes?
The speaker and creator is Graham Nelson Zutter.
Please take a moment to find a seated
position where there's support for your back and
an ability to place your feet flat on
the ground.
It may also be helpful to have a
posture where your back is fairly vertical and
there's little strain on your neck, perhaps where
your head is centered above your spinal column.
If this isn't possible, a variation includes support
behind your neck and head, perhaps with a
pillow, inviting you to find a posture where
there's very little strain on your body.
If it feels comfortable, I invite you to
close your eyes and if for any reason
it doesn't feel safe or comfortable to keep
your eyes closed, go ahead and open them
and perhaps you can find a place to
rest your gaze without too much distraction.
Perhaps there's a pattern on the wall.
If possible, I do invite you to try
eyes closed first and see what happens.
Please send your awareness and focus to the
bottoms of your feet, taking a moment to
come into contact with the floor, noticing the
stability of the floor, noticing the differences in
pressure on the bottoms of your feet.
There may be shoes, footwear, socks, carpet between
you and the floor.
Just taking a moment to feel the mixture
of firmness and softness between the bottoms of
your feet and the floor.
You may choose to sit in lotus position,
which is fine, taking a moment to notice
the contact between your feet and ankles and
where you're sitting.
As you tune into the sensation, I invite
you to use your imagination to expand your
awareness out to the entire floor of the
building that you're in.
If you're in a home, noticing how the
floor extends out to all the rooms on
this floor.
If you're in a building, noticing the floor
expanding beyond the room you're in or office
or suite that you're in to the entire
floor of this building.
Taking a moment to notice just how stable
and supportive this floor is, imagining all of
the other people and objects that this floor
supports.
And then see if your imagination can expand
to the awareness that this floor is part
of a building or a structure.
And this structure has multiple floors and a
foundation.
And the structure of this building and the
foundation that it rests upon are embedded in
the earth.
Just as you are sitting in this chair
or couch, this building is also sitting upon
the earth, receiving the support from underneath.
And see if you can notice that the
support that this building, this structure is receiving
through its foundation is traveling from the earth
up through the foundation into the structure of
this building.
And that the support is being shared up
into the very floor where you are, the
very place where your feet are in contact
with the floor.
Perhaps you can notice as well that the
chair or couch that you're sitting in is
also supported by the floor.
Taking a moment to notice the contact between
your body and your chair or couch.
Is it possible to notice that the support
that you're feeling in your body from below
is actually coming all the way from the
earth, transmitted through the foundation of the building
to the structure of the building, up through
the structure to the floor, from the floor
to your feet, and from the floor to
the couch or chair, and from the couch
or chair to your torso, holding you.
Just taking a moment to notice that the
support that you have from below, from under
you, is coming from the earth.
And perhaps it's possible to notice that you
also have structure within your body, much like
this building has structure, you too have structure
with it.
Taking a moment to notice your skeletal structure,
these bones, noticing as well that you have
tendons connecting your bones to your muscles, and
that these bones and tendons and muscles all
work together to provide the structure to your
body.
Just noticing how the structure of your body
is in contact with the external structure shared
from the earth, how you sit, the
support for your torso and legs is transmitted
from the earth to the bottoms of your
feet, your legs, your glutes and your hips,
and this support is shared with this internal
structure of your body.
One of these very special structures in your
body is your spinal column.
Perhaps you notice that there is support from
your chair or couch from behind your spine,
becoming aware of that support from your lower
back and middle back and upper back and
shoulders, noticing these supports from the outside, and
also shifting your awareness to the internal support
of your spine, noticing this column of vertebrae,
starting at your hips, going all the way
up to your neck, providing the structure and
support within.
Maybe you notice at the very top of
your spinal column is where your head is
attached, and much like your body is sitting
in this chair or couch, your head is
supported by your spinal column.
Just taking a moment to notice that the
support that you feel for your head to
your spinal column and your body also arrives
from outside of your body, from behind with
your back support and also below through the
chair or couch, supported by the floor, noticing
again that the floor receives this support through
the structure of the building, the foundation of
this building, and from the earth.
At this moment, at this time, the support
that you're receiving is shared with the earth.
Maybe taking a moment to see if it's
possible to receive even more of that support.
There may even be a sensation of appreciation
for having the structure, this intact body
with its bones and tendons and muscles, and
the awareness that the support that we're receiving
at this moment is shared to us from
the earth.
Next, I invite you to shift your attention
to your breathing.
When you inhale, maybe you can feel a
sensation of expansion within.
When you exhale, a sensation of relaxation and
release.
When you inhale, perhaps you can imagine this
nourishing oxygen coming into your body, maybe becoming
aware of your lungs, sharing this oxygen with
the nourishing blood in your body, this oxygen
spreading throughout your tissues for your cells to
absorb.
Each of your cells going about their work,
their individual functions, all supported by every in
-breath.
Also noticing that as your cells work, as
they take in that oxygen, they also release
carbon dioxide.
And as the blood circulates in your body,
sharing the oxygen, it also picks up and
carries away the unneeded carbon dioxide.
This carbon dioxide travels to your lungs.
And as the in-breath brings in oxygen,
the out-breath the exhale releases carbon dioxide.
Every exhale allows us to release what the
body no longer needs.
And as we exhale, we breathe out into
the air.
And this air is shared with other living
beings.
Some of these living beings are plants.
Some of them are trees.
Just taking a moment to see if you
can imagine a tree, if you can imagine
that when you exhale, the carbon dioxide that
your body releases travels through the air and
eventually makes its way to a tree.
Whether this tree has leaves or needles, it
probably has green.
Just noticing the parts of your tree that
have this color.
And this green color is special because it
comes from the chlorophyll within the cells of
this tree, within the tree's leaves or needles.
And what's so special about this chlorophyll is
that it's able to absorb that carbon dioxide
that you exhaled.
And as this tree stands tall under sunlight,
the photons from the sun arrive into the
chlorophyll, combining with the carbon dioxide from your
breath.
And when the photons hit the carbon dioxide
within the chlorophyll of these leaves or needles,
something pretty miraculous happens.
The photon knocks the oxygen free, leaving
the carbon for the tree to grow.
At the same time, the tree releases this
oxygen that it doesn't need, the very oxygen
that's so nourishing for your body.
Just as you inhale oxygen and exhale carbon
dioxide, trees inhale carbon dioxide and combine
it with light.
And through this combination of carbon dioxide and
light, the tree grows and releases oxygen, taking
in carbon dioxide and releasing oxygen and sharing
that oxygen in the very same air that
you breathe.
At this very moment, as you inhale, some
of that nourishing oxygen that's coming in your
body is from this very tree that you're
imagining.
And as you exhale, some of the carbon
dioxide that you're releasing into the air is
the same carbon dioxide absorbed by this tree.
Just taking a moment to notice the support
and reciprocity of this relationship.
As we breathe, so do the trees.
You absorb their oxygen, nourishing your body, and
release carbon dioxide.
This carbon dioxide is absorbed by the tree,
combined with light from the sun, and is
transformed into the very same oxygen that is
so nourishing for your body.
I invite you for a moment to notice
this tree that has come to mind, noticing
whether it has leaves or needles, maybe noticing
if it has bark.
Is the bark smooth?
Is it bumpy?
Does it have ridges?
Maybe noticing if your tree is tall.
Is it wide?
Taking a moment to notice if your tree
has bows or bows and branches.
Noticing the shape of the trunk.
I invite you to just take a moment
to see if it would be okay to
come and sit under this tree.
Perhaps there's a spot where you can even
rest your back against the trunk.
Just taking a moment to sit here and
rest.
Perhaps you can feel the roots of the
tree under you as they reach into the
earth.
Maybe these roots even provide a structure for
you to sit on or around.
And also taking a moment to feel the
strength and the stability of the trunk of
this tree as you rest against it.
Looking up, perhaps you notice the canopy of
this tree reaching over you, providing shade and
protection from the weather.
Maybe you feel like taking a nap here,
or maybe you have a book with you
or music to listen to.
Just inviting you to really rest and enjoy
this time with your tree.
There's nothing required for you to do.
Whatever you choose to do is just for
you.
Something you enjoy or like doing.
Just taking some time to enjoy this moment
with yourself and
noticing the relationship between you and this tree.
Maybe giving yourself some appreciation and acknowledgement for
taking a moment to relax, to do something
that pleases you.
And if it feels okay with you, maybe
even imagine saying thank you to this tree.
Maybe offering the tree a smile.
Maybe even placing your hand on the trunk
of this tree.
And when it feels right, just inviting you
to imagine just waving goodbye, knowing you'll see
this tree again.
Taking a moment now to notice that you're
in a room.
Perhaps your therapist is here with you.
Just gently inviting you to open your eyes.
Gently return to the shared space.